[Music]
welcome back and we are honored to be
joined
now by a heisman trophy winner davonte
we get plenty of guests
not many heisman trophy winners so it is
an extreme pleasure
to have alabama receiver on his way to
the nfl as one of the top draft picks
devante smith on the show
where's the trophy still in tuscaloosa
um how heavy is that thing
it's real heavy a lot heavier than i
thought
wait so why is why is it in tuscaloosa
though
why why is it there what's what's it in
like you mean like the school's holding
it for you or you got like a
your dorm where is it at they they hold
and they [ __ ]
okay all right so you will get it back
and put it in your house at some point
right
and then you'll put it on display when
you get all this new nfl big money
that's the player all right good
one of the things i'm always fascinated
by when we're talking to a guy who's
just
incredibly fast when did you
realize as a kid that you were just
faster than everyone else what was the
moment where you were like holy crap i'm
faster than everyone
uh i wouldn't say it was just a moment
like that because
coming up i wasn't the fastest person
that kind of just came out of nowhere so
probably
my senior high school when it kind of
came and i was like okay
i got some speed with me now
but what is it something that just
happened one day you rolled out of bed
and all of a sudden you're faster than
everyone else um
track just running track and then i
ended up on the 4x1 team and i was like
all right i must be fast if i'm on this
well all right like i'm amazed by your
speed and first off
it never looks like you're running full
speed that that's the first thing
and like just like ballpark i know you
don't want to put yourself
out there but if you if you had to run
the 40 next week or whatever or just
have a little time to practice it like
where do you think what kind of range we
talking about with you mr heisman
uh i say hi four or three low four four
okay right in that range there what yeah
would you are you the fastest guy
on the alabama team is there anybody
like that you know made you
nervous if you had to raise them in a 40
or 100 or anything like that or are you
the
self-proclaimed fastest guy on the team
i say water probably the only one
waddle's the only one that makes you
nervous
yeah and like when you guys race i mean
we're talking dead heat because i'm sure
some of the workouts and things you guys
run 40s and 50s are part of your
workouts
like what break down that race does he
get you out of the blocks do you
do you run him down as it goes along how
does that work
yeah he'll get me out of the blocks but
i eventually wrote down
hey devonte one of the reasons i love
talking to the alabama guys you've had
at the college level an nfl coach
for all practical purposes in nick saban
give us your best
nick saban story um
just every day at practice him just come
over trash talking to me saying he can
cover me he can cover me one-on-one and
things like that
we have every day
what does he do is he get up in your
face the line and jam you
and we'll be going over to the next part
of practice here just coming from me and
start backpacking and be like yeah i can
cover you in today
you got so many talented players down
there but
i gotta ask you of course you're a
receiver i mean you got
a quarterback who went in the top five
last year you got a quarterback that
sounds like it's going to be a first
round pick this year
like kind of tell us about the two
really like some of the differences
and the similarities of of what makes
both of those quarterbacks damn good
uh both of my great quarterbacks um i
would say just
how they look at everything one of them
he
he's um he's going to go to the film
room and he's going to see everything
and coming into the game
he's going to know everything you're
going to do and
the other one he's just going to come
out there and he's going to see it right
when it's going to happen and
he knows where he's going to go with the
ball gotcha all right so which one was
which there like
you you so you're saying like there's
two of the guy that
is on the field and just gonna figure it
out and go with the ball or which one
was which there
yeah two is gonna be the one that's
gonna go on the field he's gonna figure
it out and matt's gonna be the one
that's gonna
watch the film and know before he even
gets out there so one's a computer
and the other one's a little bit more of
a play backyard style of football that
was that was
what you know you had to adjust to as
far as the quarterback
yeah just adapting to each one of them
everybody plays different so
right just getting with them and
adapting to their play style
okay so the biggest stage in college
football the national championship game
you come out with 215 yards
and three touchdowns on 12 catches in
the first half
of the game when do you know in a moment
like that
that it's just it's just clicking this
is my night and i'm just going to
dominate these guys on the other side of
the line
um honestly it don't you don't really
notice it until you go to the sideline
and somebody brings it up and then
that's going to hit you like
wow that's what i'm doing like when
you're in the game you're just locked in
you're not really paying attention to it
uh 12 catches it don't feel like i had
12 catches
but you really don't notice it to
somebody on sideline eventually saying
something about it
and then the injury was such a strange
fluke thing on one hand it's amazing it
doesn't happen more often with all those
bodies that are moving around on a
football field
but it just like looked like wrong place
wrong time fingers hit a guy and
one got bent back and uh that that
looked like
it was awfully damn painful in the
moment
um honestly it wasn't painful until we
went to
ten they started pulling on it when it
happened it didn't really hurt i just
looked at it and just looked weird so i
was like okay let me go over here and
see what they got to say about it
it's gotta eat at you a little bit to go
like
i mean i know i had a good day in 200
over 200 yards but
you got to be wondering when that game's
over like what would have been if i
could have played the whole
game i mean don't you doesn't that
bother you a little bit
um what bothers me is that what stood
out the most me is that if i caught the
ball i would've never been in that
situation so
that's what i think about the most just
i would have caught that pass my finger
wouldn't be like this
damn i like you man i like you a lot
look at you self scouting yourself
that's right catch the damn ball what
the hell are you doing out there
well you know the other thing i i'm just
i always love to ask this because you're
alabama it's the sec i you guys are the
king of college football the
the conference and you guys specifically
best player
you played against in college football
don't give me any alabama teammates
buddy love
but the best player you played in your
years there uh at alabama
um i'll probably say
noah from auburn the cornerback iggy
bonye
the one that got drafted by the miami
dolphins at the end of the first round
yeah right okay that's that's a good one
i'll take that what
what about his game impressed you so
much that gave you issues
um he just switched everything up he
switched his technique so
um i always kept you guessing ain't
never play ever play the same so
it just kind of kept me on my toes just
having to switch things up a lot more
you know with no scouting combine this
year at least not the normal type of
thing with the workouts that
that everyone gets ready for and your
pro day is coming up at some point down
the road but
what do you do now to keep yourself busy
are you just focused on getting ready
for your pro day
uh yeah that just training rehabbing
um that's really just the main thing and
just trying to get to pro day
as healthy as i can and be ready to do
what i can do
now the finger how's that is it healing
pretty well right now
everything looking good with it yeah
he's doing good
are you gonna have one of those like
jacked up tory holt fingers when you
retire
or they get it all straightened out so
it's going to be fine
he's going to straighten out that's good
that's good i
might look i never i never i never
played football higher than grade school
and look at mine
from getting it i can't show you my
middle finger because that'd get us in
trouble but my fingers all screwed up
just from
having a basketball hit it four or five
times so uh that's good that your finger
is going to straighten out uh because
that
that's a painful and uh and potentially
ugly injury blah blah blah tell them to
cry your river devonte
jeez holy cow you know i heard it i
should have straight fingers
back in 1924 he's going to tell you
about it wasn't that long ago
it wasn't that long it's close it wasn't
that long ago all right i got to ask you
one question about a little the elephant
in the room and i'm
first off i'm proud of you i just before
before i asked this question
and i hope you don't do it going in the
future but it made news
right you didn't weigh in at the combine
oh no
he didn't weigh in the fastest guy in
college football we don't know how he
weighed
you know just go like what was your
decision in that and what are you gonna
do going forward
i mean i just came out of season i
really had time to train so right
listen to my pro just do something like
that just feel like that was the best
thing for me to do
yeah good for you and keep doing that
don't let them pressure you into you
they can you can always stand by
hey look at the film you know how much i
weighed there i don't know but i scored
a touchdown and they'll they'll
buy that you'll be all right other last
last thing for me
at least just because i love to hear
this too and i know you got to talk
about some auto trader
but i know you're a fan who's who's the
guy you're most excited to see in person
when you get in the nfl and get on an
nfl playing field
oh
the other devante from now on if you
misspell my name make sure
it's devonte cause he's that boy damn he
was giving you love
uh that's pretty cool so you respect his
game in a lot of ways
yes sir and i want to go back to the
weight thing because i also respect what
you did there you know
my response in a situation like that if
you got a concern about
how tall i am how heavy i am don't draft
me let somebody else draft me let
somebody from your division
draft me instead if you got any issues
with me because
i've shown you what i can do it doesn't
matter how big i am it doesn't matter
how much i weigh
i've shown everyone what i can do so
don't draft me and then you'll have to
deal with me
on the opposing team
it's all god's plan i mean i can't
control what people think so that's what
they want to do
to let them do it and um just control
what i control
i mean when i get the opportunity to do
what i do just make the most of my
opportunity
all right tell us what you have going on
with auto trader devonte
autotrader is the go-to source when car
shopping and with everything going on
with me training
and me rehabbing um i'm real busy so
they make purchasing a car a whole lot
easier and that's probably going to be
my first big purchase
is get in the car so them helping me out
makes things a whole lot easier on me
oh baby auto trader oh man mike florio
he's got that new money too
what kind of car are we gonna get there
mr heisman new money auto trader
what's that say that again oh you're
gonna get the g
wagon look at you big pimpin and the g
wagon okay i like it i can get behind
that
good thing you're going to be a first
round pick because you'll be able to
afford it now
hey devonte eventually you'll have a
rolls-royce like sims
no you're better than me and i don't
have one so get that rolls royce so i
can live vicariously through you man
keep going you're awesome we enjoy
watching you play dude
hey devonta congratulations on
everything you've done and all the best
is the draft approach as we look forward
to talking to you again real soon
thank you hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports